à dijon rallier le centre-ville au
campus universitaire et vice versa c'est
simple et rapide pour les étudiants mais
ça n'est pas bon marché on à 315 euros
par an pour les 18 25 ans donc il ya un
tarif jeune et non un tarif étudiant
c'est ce qui pose le plus sous 6 parce
que tous les étudiants ne sont pas
forcément jeunes et tous les jeunes ne
sont pas forcément étudiants il ya des
jeunes qui travaillent et il ya des
personnes qui veulent reprendre les
études à un âge plus avancé
et de fait cette grille tarifaire ne
comporte pas de tarif étudiant depuis
2015 le mécontentement des étudiants
dijonnais s'exprime quasiment à chaque
rentrée sur ce sujet mais dijon et la
métropole assume ce choix nous avons
acté la décision depuis quelques années
n'ont pas d'appliquer des tarifs en
fonction du statut mais sur la base de
deux critères la tranche d'âge et le
niveau de ressources
nous avons donc dans nos tableaux de
tarification deux éléments la
tarification de base et la tarification
solidaire
c'est une logique globale on peut pas
appliquer la tarification solidaire à
l'ensemble du monde étudiant
nous avons décidé de sa blonde et
définir des critères d'éligibilité qui
est tout simplement le quotient familial
et le niveau de ressources à dijon le
tarif solidaire 15 euros mensuels et
réservées aux boursiers des échelons 6
et 7
les bourses les plus élevés juste en
dessous on paye plein pot
d'où ce cas de figure très répandue on
est précaire n'est pas tout à fait assez
pauvre pour bénéficier des aides
face à cette situation l'unef exprime
ses revendications
élargir le tarif boursier a plus
d'échelon et obtenir un tarif étudiant
vrai vraiment à part alors ce système
tarifaire critiqué depuis plusieurs
années va t'il un peu évolué en tout cas
il fera encore l'objet de discussions
entre les organisations étudiantes et
dijon métropole